welcome back your insurance agency the
sponsors of this next segment want to
remind you that unplanned circumstances
can impact your health coverage here's
what you need to know
welcome back to your insurance agency at
the meadows mall what do you need to
know before the soon approaching open
enrollment period starts president chris
carruthers and his team have the answers
we have many opportunities to help you
qualify for insurance today or possibly
get you a special enrollment period to
help you get access to more care and to
maybe lowering your cost of health care
something to think about though life
events that impact your health coverage
there are some factors that may impact
your ability to afford your insurance
so sometimes when we have an impact of
income maybe loss of job or even an
increase in pay
those are opportunities that may give
you a special enrollment period to help
adjust your medical benefits so we've
had we've had changes in the medical
industry here in nevada such as doctors
switching plans or networks
and as well as access to certain
procedures have been a challenge for
many of us here and we actually will
help you navigate those situations
lastly we sometimes are dealing with a
human crisis
such as maybe cancer
or other concerns we want to make sure
those services are covered we have to be
very careful of the plans we select
because some of those plans do not cover
pre-existing conditions
and or have limits on benefits and your
insurance agency helps you choose the
plan that best suits your needs they
want you to have full coverage and no
limits
what is important for our viewers to
know
is that we need your help to help you
navigate what's best for you so for
example
income
do you realize we have special
enrollment periods based on your income
as an individual that's on medicare if
your income is under twenty five hundred
dollars a month for under thirty five
hundred dollars a month as a couple we
have programs to help you right now to
help you afford
your benefits but also get you a special
enrollment period
also for those individuals who are on a
medicare supplement policy do you
realize we have a birthday rule in
nevada which means we can actually move
you on your birth month
every year to a lower cost medicare
supplement plan so if you believe you're
eligible for a special enrollment period
please give us a call we have brokers
ready to serve you right now
we have even systems to where we can
load your medications and your doctors
to make sure we hit a hundred percent so
that we make sure you're fully covered
now it's time to consider something that
can affect everyone like a recession
your insurance agency can help you
navigate that too as our financial
situations have changed we're all
looking for ways to save money
your insurance agency is here to help
you
navigate looking for those resources to
save money based on your eligibility for
special enrollment periods since 1969
your insurance agency has reminded
people that they don't have to walk
alone regardless the crisis chris and
his team have you covered sometimes we
run into situations that are unplanned
events
like we think it's never going to happen
to us such as cancer
one of the difficult things that we've
had to help people navigate is access to
the doctors that are best treat their
condition
and that's one of the many things we do
here at your insurance agency
[Music]
thank you to your insurance agency for
sponsoring this segment you can find
them inside the meadows mall for more
information call 702-425-5500
or visit y i a nv dot com slash life
dash events we'll be right back